Each harness is a bit different. And like, I even asked it. I was like, Yeah, I, I've run into this a lot where, like, harness differences, especially when you're doing like multi-agent orchestration stuff, you become very tied to the particular way that a harness works and that the harnesses tool, tooling works. And, like, I ran it, I had this weird thing where, like, initially I couldn't get,
每个 harness（驱动框架）都略有不同。而且，甚至连我自己也问过它。我当时就想，是的，我，我经常遇到这种情况，就是 harness 的差异——特别是当你做多智能体编排之类的事情时，你会变得非常依赖于某个特定的 harness 运作方式以及该 harness 的工具链。而且，就像，我运行它时遇到了一个奇怪的情况，一开始我无法让，
I couldn't get models other than Opus to, like, drive ClaudeCode well. And I thought that the models just were not capable of handling this workflow. But it turned out that really there was just, like, a bug in the structure of my skills, that when it was going to launch, you know, a sub-agent, the way it was describing what to do was just not correct in that there was a better way to do this. And with Opus, for, you know, maybe because they post-trained it to, for the harness specifically, or for whatever reason, it just was sort of smoothing over this, you know, this bug in my skills.
除了 Opus 之外的模型很好地驱动 ClaudeCode。我以为这些模型根本无法处理这种工作流。但事实证明，实际上只是我的技能（skills）结构里有一个 bug，当它准备启动，你知道的，一个子智能体时，它描述要做什么的方式是不正确的，其实有更好的方法来实现这一点。而使用 Opus 时，可能因为他们专门针对 harness 对其进行了后训练，或者出于某种原因，它就这样，某种程度上平息了，你知道的，我技能里的这个 bug。
Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 291 recorded on June 10th, 2026. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about auto research, the top LLM's Opus 4.8, GPT5.5. Deepseek V4, Codex, Coddcode, and more. I'm good. We are live. I think I need a caffeinated beverage here. We're going to get the bottle. Oh yeah, it used to be a...
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 291 期，录制于 2026 年 6 月 10 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们聊聊自动研究、顶级大模型 Opus 4.8、GPT5.5、DeepSeek V4、Codex、ClaudeCode 等等。我很好。我们正在直播。我想我这里需要一杯含咖啡因的饮料。我们要去拿瓶装水。哦对，它过去是个……
Well, one sec. I mean, it used to be bubbly. I don't buy bubblies anymore now because they're too expensive. And, well, I shouldn't say they're too expensive. They're the cheapest of the sparkling waters. Currently right now, I have a president's choice grapefruit sparkling water
好吧，等一下。我是说，它以前是气泡水。我不再买 Bubbly 了，因为它们太贵了。而且，好吧，我其实不应该说它们太贵。它们是苏打水中最便宜的。目前我手头有一款 President's Choice 的葡萄柚味苏打水，
that I like quite a bit. And I believe it's, I don't know, $5 or $575 Canadian for a box of 12. Whereas bubbly a lot of these times, depending on where you buy it, ma'am, it's like $10 for 12 cans. Anyways, the listeners do not care about the price of the different sparkling waters. How's it going, man? I imagine, so we were supposed to have Dwayne Merrill requested guest by our last. guest, Marco, and he has agreed to come on, but he's rather busy. And so he asked if he could come on. We can, we don't need to, we don't need to have Dwayne on. We can just have an agent,
我非常喜欢。我想它大概是，我不知道，12 罐装售价 5 加元或 5.75 加元。而 Bubbly 很多时候，取决于你在哪买，妈的，12 罐要 10 美元左右。不管怎样，听众们才不在乎不同牌子苏打水的价格呢。最近怎么样，老兄？我想，我们本该邀请德韦恩·梅里尔（Dwayne Merrill）作为嘉宾，这也是我们上一位嘉宾马可（Marco）推荐的，他已经同意来了，但他挺忙的。所以他问是否可以来。我们可以，我们不需要，我们不需要请德韦恩来。我们只要找一个智能体，
the agent version of Dwayne on and just, just ask it. That statement is going to upset people because they're probably are not sure if you're joking or not. And he's joking, folks. He's joking. We're not going to have the, I'm joking. Yes, you are. We're not going to replace our guests with replicated LLM versions of them yet. That's also a joke, folks. Calm down. Everybody's getting upset about AI these days. And so Dwayne's not going to be on.
德韦恩的智能体版本，然后直接问它就行了。这话会惹恼大家的，因为他们可能不确定你到底是不是在开玩笑。各位，他在开玩笑。他在开玩笑。我们现在还不会用大模型的复制版本来取代我们的嘉宾。这也是个玩笑，各位。冷静点。现在每个人都对 AI 感到大惊小怪的。所以德韦恩不会上节目。
That means we're not going to be talking about the coupled lookback, Cub and other topics yet, which means we get to talk about whatever we want, which probably, if it's just Bryce and me, means we're talking about AI and LLM's folks. I heard on another podcast, Oxide and Friends, hosted by Brian Cantrell and Adam Leventhal, I believe. And they were saying that they were getting some feedback that like most of their episodes were becoming about AI and LLMs.
这意味着我们暂时不会讨论耦合回溯（coupled lookback）、Cub 和其他话题，这意味着我们可以畅所欲言，聊任何我们想聊的。既然只有布莱斯和我，那基本上就意味着我们要聊 AI 和大模型了，各位。我听了另一个播客叫 Oxide and Friends，由布莱恩·坎特雷尔（Brian Cantrell）和亚当·莱文塔尔（Adam Leventhal）主持，我想是吧。他们说收到了一些反馈，比如他们的大多数单集都变成了关于 AI 和大模型的讨论。
And they were those, that feedback was not happy about that. Listen, folks, it's hard not to be drinking the Kool-Aid and so excited about this stuff. And I know I asked Bryce how he's doing. We'll let him answer that question in a second. I'm so excited. I told my wife about this. while right after it was the wrong time to tell her about it I was picking her up from the subway she had a long day at a conference
而且那些反馈对此很不满意。听着，各位，很难不沉迷其中，对这些东西感到如此兴奋。我知道我问过布莱斯他最近怎么样。我们一会儿让他回答这个问题。我太兴奋了。我把这事告诉我老婆了。就在……当时告诉她的时机不对，我正从地铁站接她，她在会议上忙了一整天，
and she's like six and a half months pregnant and she did not respond with the enthusiasm that I was hoping for but let me tell you buddy this is let's see if you can tell what do you see on my this is my pod god podcast app what do you see on the podcast screen here I'm not sure if you can make it out in the blurriness well I see acquired I see ADSP and I see a bunch of people with purple backgrounds.
她已经怀孕六个半月了，她并没有表现出我所希望的那种热情。不过老兄，我告诉你，这，让我们看看你能不能认出来，你看到了吗，这是我的 Pod God 播客应用。你在播客屏幕上看到了什么？我不确定你能不能在模糊的画面中看清。好吧，我看到了 Acquired，我看到了 ADSP，我还看到了一堆有着紫色背景的人。
Yes. Welcome to Personality Meta Podcasts. You can't make out who these people are. Or actually, yeah, you probably can now. It's a zooming in. We got Andre Carpathie, Boris Churney, creator of Claudeco, Demis, Hasabas, founder of DeepMine, aka Google DeepMind, aka GDM. We got Elon Musk.
没错。欢迎来到个性化元播客（Personality Meta Podcasts）。你可能认不出这些人是谁。或者其实，对，你现在可能认出来了。这是一个缩放画面。我们有安德烈·卡帕西（Andrej Karpathy）、博尔西·切尔尼（Boris Cherny，ClaudeCode 的创造者）、德米斯·哈萨比斯（Demis Hassabis，DeepMind 的创始人，又名 Google DeepMind，又名 GDM）。我们有埃隆·马斯克。
We got Jensen Huang. We got Ilyas Oskivir, Miramaradi. And there's other folks, too. These are just, it's a starting list of the people that I care about. And look at that. Look at that. You hit on Jensen Huang. Let's see if I can do it.
我们有黄仁勋。我们有伊利亚·苏茨凯韦尔（Ilya Sutskever）、米拉·穆拉蒂（Mira Murati）。还有其他人。这些只是我关心的人的初始名单。瞧瞧这个。瞧瞧这个。你点到了黄仁勋。看看我能不能做到。
Boom. And you've got a list. And today was the first time it actually updated. And so now you can subscribe to someone you want to hear from, not a specific podcast. And it brings me so much joy. So much joy, folks. Because there's a lot of podcasts, for instance, no priors, Sequoia Capital, a bunch of these like venture capital, blah blah blah talking about taxes nobody cares but every once in a while people that you are interested in
砰。你就得到了一个列表。今天还是它第一次真正更新。所以现在你可以订阅你想听的人，而不是某个特定的播客。这给我带来了极大的快乐。极大的快乐，各位。因为有很多播客，例如 No Priors、红杉资本（Sequoia Capital），还有一堆这种风险投资、巴拉巴拉谈论税收的内容，没人关心。但偶尔会有你感兴趣的人
go on these podcasts and sure enough today it was training data which is i think the sequoia capital podcast jensen went on it it aired on youtube three hours ago it showed up in my podcast cue for this personality and i don't know why no one has done this before why is it me why is it some guy who's in research doing this it's fantastic and you know what the first problem what do you think the first problem that I encountered now that I have these cues are that I need to make an adjustment to. I did not expect this at all, but it was rather obvious once I saw it. And I was like, oh, yeah, that makes sense.
上这些播客。果不其然，今天就是 Training Data，我想那是红杉资本的播客，黄仁勋上过的那期。它三个小时前在 YouTube 上播出，然后就出现在了我的这个个性的播客队列中。我不知道为什么以前没有人这么做过。为什么是我？为什么是一个做研究的家伙在做这个？这太棒了。你知道我遇到的第一个问题是什么吗？当我有了这些队列之后，你觉得我遇到的第一个问题是什么？我完全没有预料到这一点，但一旦我看到了，它就相当明显了。当时我就想，哦，对，这说得通。
I can't imagine. More than 75% of the podcasts in each of these meta-podcast personalities are not in English. They are in Chinese, Japanese, German, like a lot of the Peter Steinberger. Well, then you just use one of NVIDIA's excellent, you know, speech. and translation models to automatically translate the podcast. False. I'm not spending money to translate podcasts in different languages.
我简直不敢想象。这些元播客个性化列表中，超过 75% 的播客都不是英文的。它们是中文的、日文的、德文的，就像彼得·施泰恩伯格（Peter Steinberger）的很多内容。好吧，那你就用英伟达那些优秀的，你知道的，语音和翻译模型来自动翻译播客呗。错。我可不会花钱去翻译不同语言的播客。
One could do it, but you're just going to have a filter where you choose the language. They're not very large models. You could run them on a fairly small GPU system. I mean, there is the thing where I've heard that, like, on Twitter now, they auto-translate. And so, like, you might be talking with someone in Japan that's using Japanese and that's created some interesting interactions. But when I was at the Singularity Intelligence Technology Summit in Shanghai a couple weeks ago, all the talks were in Chinese.
一个人是完全可以做到的，但你只需要设置一个过滤器来选择语言。它们并不是非常大的模型。你完全可以在一个相当小的 GPU 系统上运行它们。我是说，我听说现在在 Twitter 上，它们会自动翻译。所以，比如说，你可能会和某个使用日语的日本人在交流，这产生了一些有趣的互动。但几周前我在上海奇点智能技术峰会（Singularity Intelligence Technology Summit）时，所有的演讲都是中文的。
And so I was like, okay, well, you know, I could just use Google Translate on my phone. Or I could go spin up a GPU node and like vibe code, a deployment of, you know, one of Nvidia's new, you know, translation models, which I did. And then I learned a lot about that whole space because it's like, you know, you. You have voice to text. You have text to speech. You have, you know, speech to speech. There's, like, all sorts of different, like, you know, types of models and specialized use cases here for, like, if you want a transcription versus if you want, like, simultaneous translation.
所以当时我就想，好吧，你知道，我可以在手机上直接用谷歌翻译。或者我可以启动一个 GPU 节点，然后 vibe coding（凭感觉编程）部署英伟达的一些新的翻译模型，而我也确实这么做了。然后我学到了很多关于整个领域的知识，因为你看，你有语音转文本、文本转语音，还有语音转语音。这里有各种各样不同类型的模型和专门的用例，比如你是想要转录，还是想要同传。
And then there's this question of, like, chunking of, like, you know, the longer that you wait, the larger chunks you have, the better translation you'll typically do because you have more context. but the longer chunks you have, the more like visible latency there is. Because like if you wait to buffer up a bunch of words that somebody's saying, like a whole sentence, you're going to be able to translate it better. But if you buffer up the whole sentence and then translate the whole sentence at a time, then there's like a more of a lag from when the person spoke to when you start hearing the translation. And one of the interesting problems I ran into, I wanted a smaller model that I could deploy
然后这里还有一个分块（chunking）的问题，就是说，你等待的时间越长，分块就越大，通常翻译效果就会越好，因为你有更多的上下文。但分块越大，可见的延迟就越高。因为如果你等待缓冲别人说的许多词，比如一整句话，你就能把它翻译得更好。但如果你缓冲了整句话，然后一次性翻译整句话，那么从别人说话到你开始听到翻译之间就会有更多的滞后。我遇到的一个有趣问题是，我想要一个更小的模型，以便能够部署在
on one L40s. Tell people what that is, because honestly, I don't need. I've seen the brev instance, but I don't even know what it is. Like, I just know it's a GPU. L40S is like a, is a mid to low range GPU that is inference focused, like inference and data science focus. So it's not like a big like training GPU. So they're very common in like developer clouds.
一块 L40S 上。给大家解释一下那是什么，因为老实说，我不需要。我见过 Brev 的实例，但我甚至不知道它是什么。我只知道它是一个 GPU。L40S 是一种中低端 GPU，专注于推理，也就是推理和数据科学导向。所以它不像那种大型训练 GPU。它们在开发者云中非常常见。
Since they're not like a high end like flagship GPU, if you're just like doing like code development, you need a GPU to test on there. That's a common option to use. I've, maybe it has like 80 gigs of memory or 40 gigs of memory. I don't remember it. had some reasonable but not a, you know, flagship amount of memory and it's a slightly older chip. But so I picked a model. I was there live at the conference.
由于它们不像高端旗舰 GPU 那样，如果你只是在做代码开发，你需要一个 GPU 来进行测试，那这是一个很常见的选择。我记得，它大概有 80G 或 40G 的显存吧。我不记得了。它有合理数量的显存，但不是旗舰级别的，而且它是一个稍微旧一点的芯片。所以我就选了这样一个模型。我当时就在会议现场，
So there were like two constraints. Like one, I didn't want to, you know, go and get a beefier GPU. I could have. But that actually wasn't why I picked a smaller model. I was like, the conference is happening right now. I need to pick a model that is small enough that I can download it and like deploy it in a reasonable amount of time. And so like I, you know, I was chatting with my agent. and my agent's like, yeah, this should take like 30 minutes or so to set up.
所以有两个限制条件。第一，我不想去弄一个更强劲的 GPU。我本来可以的。但其实那并不是我选择较小模型的原因。当时的情况是，会议正在进行中，我需要选择一个足够小的模型，以便能够在合理的时间内下载并部署它。所以，你知道的，我一直在和我的智能体聊天，
But so the model that I picked was not a multilingual model. It was where I specifically downloaded a Chinese to English variant of this model. There were other models that I could have downloaded, which was just like any language to English or any language to any language, but those are necessarily bigger models. And the mistake that I made is that there was, it was a Chinese to English model. So I had to deal with code switching. So during the conference talks, someone would say something, hang on, one second, one second, Conner. Honey, I'm in the middle of recording the podcast. I understand, honey, but now, now, now Conner's going to have to edit this.
我的智能体说，嗯，这大概需要 30 分钟左右来设置。但我选择的模型并不是一个多语言模型。我专门下载了该模型的中文到英文变体。其实还有其他模型我可以下载，比如任何语言到英语，或者任何语言到任何语言，但那些必然是更大的模型。我犯的错误是，这是一个中英模型。所以我必须处理代码混合（code switching）的情况。所以在会议演讲期间，有人会说一些，等一下，等一下，康纳。亲爱的，我正在录播客呢。我明白，亲爱的，但现在，现在，现在康纳得剪辑这段了。
I picked this Chinese to English model. And, you know, then what would happen is a speaker would be, you know, talking, they'd be saying something, something, something, something, KV Cash, something, something, tense or parallelism, something. something, something KV Cash, right? Because if you're giving a technical talk, you're going to often use words that are typically English language words specific to your technical field. And if you have a model that only understands Chinese, then it hears KV Cash. And it's like, what Chinese word did you just say? And it gets very confused. And so that completely threw off the little system that I built. I mean, it did like an okay job. relative to Google Translate. And I later talked to some of the people who make the NVIDIA speech models.
我选了这个中英模型。然后，你知道的，接下来的情况是，演讲者在讲话，他们会说一些，一些，一些，KV Cache，一些，一些，张量并行（tensor parallelism），一些，一些，一些 KV Cache，对吧？因为如果你在做技术演讲，你经常会使用特定于你技术领域的英文单词。如果你的模型只懂中文，当它听到“KV Cache”时，就会想：你刚刚说的到底是什么中文词？它就会感到非常困惑。这彻底打乱了我构建的小系统。我的意思是，它表现得还行，比起谷歌翻译来说。我后来和英伟达语音模型的某些制作人员交流过，
And they told me, you know, the model that you used had picked a slightly older version of our SDK. You should have used this instead. So I'm never at a future conference where all the talks are in a different language. Maybe I'll have a chance to rebuild that thing. Anyways. Well, no, I just, I feel like it's so, it's so, maybe we should spend this episode. We should just talk about the different things. You know, you're using this for.
他们告诉我，你用的那个模型选了我们 SDK 的一个稍旧版本。你本来应该用这个的。所以我绝不会在未来的所有演讲都是另一种语言的会议上再犯这种错了。也许我会有机会重新构建那个东西。不管怎样。好吧，不，我只是觉得，这太，这太，也许我们应该把这一集的大部分时间花在聊聊这些不同的事情上。你知道的，你正在用它来做这些。
To be clear, this was a thing where I, like, built and stood this up. Like, it was a two-day conference and I, like, built and stood it up and had, like, a nice little web app and, like, app on my phone for this in, like, a matter of hours. It was very fun. Yeah. I mean, you can use, oh, man, it's just. But, but, but honestly, like, like, doing that, like, oh, building some little, like app like that, like, that's, that's, like, so, like, three months ago. I'm all about, I'm all about the auto, like, so. So, okay, the fun part for the listener here is somebody pointed, like, we have this codex leaderboard within a video.
澄清一下，这是一个我亲自动手搭建的东西。这只是一个为期两天的会议，我在短短几个小时内就把这个东西搭建好了，并且弄了一个精美的小网页应用以及手机上的应用。这太有趣了。对啊。我的意思是，你可以用，哦，天哪，这简直……但是，但是，老实说，像那样，做一些这样的小应用，这，这已经是三个月前的过时做法了。我现在全神贯注于自动化的东西，所以。所以，好吧，对听众来说有趣的部分是，有人指出，我们在英伟达内部有一个 codex 排行榜。
Jesus. And how did you find out about that? I don't know if we should. I don't know. Somebody pinged me because I was 31 on there. So Connor is number seven on the codex leaderboard. And you might think that that, you might think that that means that Connor is winning. However, the reality is that I stopped.
天哪。你是怎么发现那个的？我不知道我们是否应该说这个。我不知道。有人 @ 我，因为我当时排在第 31 位。所以康纳在 codex 排行榜上排名第七。你可能会认为，这意味着康纳赢了。然而现实情况是，我停下来了。
I don't want to be high on this leaderboard when when people get fired for spending too many tokens. I had to stop use. So at NVIDIA, we have, you know, a corporate, like, subscription to Kodx, a corporate subscription to Klaude where we pay it, like, API billing rates. But then, like most big tech companies, we also have our own LLM gateway. And I had to stop using our corporate Claude code subscription because I just hit the cap too quickly. And likewise for codex, well, it's less about likewise for Kodak.
当人们因为消耗太多 token 而被炒鱿鱼时，我可不想在这个排行榜上名列前茅。我不得不停止使用。在英伟达，我们有一个针对 Codex 的企业订阅，一个我们按 API 计费标准付费的 Claude 企业订阅。但就像大多数大型科技公司一样，我们也有自己的 LLM 网关。我不得不停止使用我们的企业版 Claude Code 订阅，因为我实在消耗太快，触及了上限。Codex 也是如此，呃，不过 Codex 倒不完全是这样。
all of the like billing and like metering for these things like it's awful like with like I feel like I could never know you know what how many tokens I was using or like how much it was costing and so I just moved all of my usage to our invidia inference hub and centralized it there so the the 31 rank which I'm surprised that I was that high but I guess I did do a bunch last week before I split about a bunch last month before you're primarily using cloud code right? That was only a chunk of my usage. I was primarily using opus. I do primarily use Claude code as a harness. I do find it to be the strongest harness for the sort of stuff that I'm doing, which is long horizon tasks with complex multi-agent workflows that require multiple concurrent agents and multiple
所有这些计费和计量机制简直糟透了——我觉得我永远无法知道自己用了多少 token，或者花了多少钱。所以我干脆把所有的使用量都转移到了我们的英伟达推理中心，并在那里集中管理。所以第 31 的排名——我很惊讶自己能排这么高，但我想上个月在我分心之前，我确实做了很多，在我疯狂使用之前……你主要在使用 Claude Code 对吧？那只是我使用量的一部分。我主要在使用 Opus。我确实主要把 Claude Code 作为 harness。我发现它是我目前所做工作的最强 harness，也就是需要多个并发智能体和多个
concurrent agents that are running tool calls that need to be carefully synchronized with each other and concurrency safe. And I have found that Claude Codd codes model for subagents and subagent completion and waiting on subagents is better than codexes. Because in codex, I've seen in codex, like basically there's like a thing that you call. to like wait on subagents. And like you have to like explicitly call that by at least my understanding to get like notifications of when stuff finishes. Whereas in Claude code, if you start a background agent, it will eventually send a completion notification. And so I've had more issues in codex with subagents completing and the manager agent not being aware of that. And I also just in general have
并发智能体运行工具调用的复杂多智能体工作流的长周期任务，并且这些工具调用需要仔细相互同步且具备并发安全性。我发现 Claude Code 用于子智能体、子智能体完成以及等待子智能体的模型比 Codex 更好。因为在 Codex 中，我见过，基本上就是有一个你需要调用的东西
found GPT 5.5 to, uh, I don't know, not be as good. The models that I, I'm working with these days is Opus 4.8, GPT 5.5, deep seek V4 Pro, and uh, uh, Nemotron 3 Ultra. And now I'm doing like complex stuff where I have like different, like I have like one model as the manager and then different models as the workers and stuff like that. Yeah. It's, and, and, well, I don't know how much we should tell people about this leaderboard, but I was, I was shocked. I, when I found out when because Bryce ping me yesterday and he's like congrats on being number seven and I I was like because the thing is is I keep waiting I know that you you've received your manager has received a
来等待子智能体完成。而且据我所知，你必须显式调用它才能获得关于任务何时完成的通知。而在 Claude Code 中，如果你启动一个后台智能体，它最终会发送完成通知。因此，在 Codex 中我遇到了更多关于子智能体完成而管理智能体却不知情的问题。而且总的来说，我也发现 GPT 5.5，呃，怎么说呢，没有那么好。我最近在使用的模型是 Opus 4.8、GPT 5.5、DeepSeek V4 Pro 和 Nemotron 3 Ultra。现在我正在做一些复杂的任务，比如用一个模型作为管理者，然后用不同的模型作为工作者之类的。是的。而且，而且，好吧，我不知道我们该跟人们透露多少关于这个排行榜的信息，但我当时很震惊。当我发现的时候，因为布莱斯昨天 @ 我，他说祝贺你排名第七，然后我就想——因为问题是，我一直在等待，我知道你，你的经理已经收到过
couple emails about your spend I have not been notified about any emails of what my spend is and so I just always assume if I haven't received any emails like I'm not hitting some threshold but the fact that I'm number seven on this list out of like 25,000 people using Codex is, I would expect there to have been an email, you know, like, is, I really hope this isn't costing the company. It's, it's because we're doing the same thing. It's because we're both doing, we're both doing like auto research. Yeah, yeah, orchestration of multiple agents running at the same time. And I mean, that's the thing is like, no offense. You can tell me if I have to cut this or we can keep this in. We had, but it was just like there was another guy I should I should find it but there's a guy that recently
几封关于你的花费的邮件了。我可没有收到任何关于我花费多少的邮件通知。所以我总是假设，只要我没收到任何邮件，就说明我没有触及某个阈值。但事实上，在所有使用 Codex 的大约 25,000 人中，我竟然能排到第七位，我本以为应该会收到一封邮件的，你知道的，我真的希望这没有给公司造成太大的成本。这是因为我们在做同样的事情。这是因为我们俩都在做，都在做自动研究。是的，是的，编排多个智能体同时运行。我的意思是，事情就是这样，恕我直言。你可以告诉我我是不是得把这段剪掉，或者我们可以保留它。我们有，不过就是有个另外的家伙——我应该找找他——有一个最近
joined in video from Google that gave an internal talk at a software engineering something let me find the name of this guy and I'm not sure if he's given the name of the talk was or the name of the event is agent native tools and coding and if I open it it hopefully will show me the name of this guy If I hit the play button, is it Colt, Mick, Anless? I probably butcher the pronunciation of that, of that name. But he gave, like, a talk that's, like, eight stages of agentic coding. And, like, level one is, like, you know, chat GPT or Gemini in, like, a browser using their web interface. And then, like, step two is, like, a CLI, you know, command line interface.
从谷歌加入英伟达的家伙在一个软件工程相关活动中做了一个内部演讲。让我找找这家伙的名字，我不确定他给出的演讲名称或者活动名称是不是叫“智能体原生工具与编码（Agent Native Tools and Coding）”。如果我打开它，希望它能显示这个家伙的名字。如果我按下播放键，是叫 Colt、Mick、Anless 吗？我可能把那个名字的发音给搞砸了。但他做了一个演讲，类似于“智能体化编码的八个阶段”。第一阶段，比如说，是在浏览器里使用 ChatGPT 或 Gemini 的网页界面。然后第二阶段，比如说，是 CLI（命令行界面）。
And then you get all the way to step eight. And it's like, you're developing. I think what he called it was a knowledge garden, and you have like an orchestration system where you've got... Anyways, the... We'll probably have to trim parts of... Good chunks of this. Anyways, we'll just say that the talk that Colt,
然后你一直到第八阶段。这就好比你在开发——我想他称之为“知识花园（knowledge garden）”，你拥有一个编排系统，里面有……不管怎样，我们可能得修剪掉一部分……很大一部分。不管怎样，我们只想说，Colt 做的那场演讲——
who recently in the last year, I think he said, had joined Nvidia that he gave, was, in my opinion, a hundred times more valuable because it shows what at the limit you can do with these tools. At the limit, this is what... you can aspire to be doing with these tools because like at the limit it's amazing how good these tools are and yeah so i'm going to i don't worry about how much the inference i'm using costs and there's a couple of reasons for that and i'll explain i would worry if the the thing that i was
他是在过去一年里加入英伟达的，我想他是这么说的——在我看来，这场演讲的价值高出百倍，因为它展示了你在极限状态下可以用这些工具做些什么。在极限状态下，这就是你渴望用这些工具达到的境界，因为在极限状态下，这些工具的强大程度令人惊叹。所以，是的，我不会去担心我消耗的推理成本到底多少，这有几个原因，我来解释一下。如果我正在做的事情
doing did not seem incredibly valuable but i i'm very very confident that the thing that i was doing that I'm doing, the general area that I'm working in, is incredibly, incredibly valuable. So that's a big part of it. I know there's a bunch of other people doing similar stuff. And a lot of them are more worried about like token efficiency first. My first concern is capability and functionality. Can we build a thing that does what, you know, that does this incredibly valuable work. And I think it's a lot easier to first prove that we can build the thing that is incredibly valuable and then later figure out how to optimize it and reduce its costs. And I've just sort of started on that process on figuring out how to do that. But if you go in with a mindset
看起来并没有那么不可思议的价值，我才会去担心。但我非常非常确信，我正在做的事情，我所从事的这个总体领域，有着极其巨大、不可思议的价值。所以这是很大一部分原因。我知道还有很多其他人也在做类似的事情。他们中的许多人首先担心的是 token 的效率。而我首先关心的则是能力和功能。我们能否构建一个能够完成这种极具价值工作的系统？我认为，首先证明我们能够构建出极具价值的东西，然后再去想办法优化它并降低成本，要容易得多。而我才刚刚开始摸索如何做到这一点。但如果你抱着这样一种心态——
of, oh, I'm not going to use the frontier model because it's too expensive. then you won't know what is capable. And in particular, if you're doing something like auto research, the real value of auto research is in discovering novel ideas. It's almost like basic research, you know, like answering the questions of the universe. The value in auto research is when it can be an idea factory, when it can come up with things that are like net new novel that aren't in literature that you look at and you're like, hmm, you know, if I had assigned a, you know, a senior engineer,
哦，我不会使用前沿模型，因为它太贵了——那么你永远不会知道它的极限能力是什么。特别是，如果你在做自动研究之类的事情，自动研究真正的价值在于发现新颖的想法。这几乎就像基础科学研究一样，你知道的，去解答宇宙的奥秘。自动研究的价值在于，当它能成为一个创意工厂时，当它能想出那些文献中没有的、全新的、你看了之后会想“嗯，如果我指派了一个资深工程师、
a researcher, you know, to go work on this for six months, this is the sort of thing of novel revelation that I would expect to come out of that. And I think a lot of people don't have the right philosophy when they think about things like auto research because they're focused on, they're focused on determinism. They're focused on like an efficient and clean process. But that's not typically how humans birth like new ideas. Like if you have an open question, you have to have an open search space and there will be failure. That is part of the process. The other reason why I don't worry so much about my inference usage is because I think it's very clear that this is going to have a huge transformative impact on our industry. And part of my job, my mandate at Nvidia, is to figure out how people program our platform.
一个研究员花六个月时间来研究这个，这正是我所期望产生的突破性新知”的成果时。我认为很多人在思考自动研究之类的事情时，并没有正确的哲学理念，因为他们过于专注于确定性。他们专注于一个高效且干净的过程。但这通常不是人类诞生新想法的方式。如果你有一个开放式的问题，你就必须有一个开放式的搜索空间，而且失败是不可避免的。这本来就是过程的一部分。我不太担心我的推理消耗的另一个原因，是因为我认为很明显，这将对我们的行业产生巨大的变革性影响。我的工作之一，我在英伟达的使命，就是弄清楚人们如何为我们的平台编程。
And, you know, I think of myself often as being a power user of things, right? I'm not necessarily a compiler engineer or a driver engineer, but I am a power user of those things. And so for me to learn what the best practices should be, I got to go around and try crazy stuff, you know? Like I got to go and see like, okay, like what happens if I go and throw, you know, 50 agents at, you know, winning the GPU mode leaderboard? You know, what can I learn from that process? So, you know, if you're just going and burning tokens and your only output of burning those tokens is like the output of the task, then that's maybe more questionable than if your outputs is not only what the task achieved, but also analyzing how it got there and learning from how it got
而且，你知道的，我经常认为自己是各种事物的高级用户（power user），对吧？我不一定是一个编译器工程师或驱动程序工程师，但我确实是这些东西的高级用户。所以为了摸索出最佳实践是什么，我必须四处尝试一些疯狂的东西，你知道的？比如我必须去看看，好吧，如果我放出 50 个智能体去争夺 GPU 模式排行榜的榜首，会发生什么？我能从这个过程中学到什么？所以，如果你只是在烧 token，而烧这些除了任务结果之外没有产生任何其他产出，那或许还有所商榷；但如果你的产出不仅包括任务达成的成果，还包括分析它是如何走到这一步的、并从中吸取教训，
there. And using the data of, okay, I, I, you know, I spent 20 billion tokens to do this thing. That's a lot of data that you've generated. And how can you learn from that about how parts of your stack could be more agent ready, more efficient? You know, how could you improve your APIs, your tools, et cetera? So, like, yeah, I'm spending a lot of tokens, but I get a ton out of those tokens because now I have all this data and I can go and ask questions about this data. Like the other day, like, there's a particular command line tool in Vida and like people are always asking me, Bryce, how do we make our thing, our piece of software like agent ready and agent friendly?
并且利用这些数据——比如，我为了完成这件事消耗了 200 亿个 token。你生成了大量的数据。你如何从中学习，了解你的技术栈有哪些部分可以变得更加“智能体就绪（agent-ready）”、更加高效？你知道的，你如何改进你的 API、你的工具等等？所以，是的，我消耗了大量的 token，但我从这些 token 中获得了巨大的回报，因为现在我拥有了所有这些数据，我可以去向这些数据提出问题。就像前几天，英伟达有一个特定的命令行工具，人们总是问我：“布莱斯，我们该如何让我们的软件变得对智能体更友好（agent-ready and agent-friendly）？”
And the other day, I was just like, you know what? I'm just going to go like, hey, like, go to cloud. Like, here's where all the data is. Just like go, like, go look for all the times that this particular tool was used. And like, give me, give me information about like every time we called this tool and did it succeed or did it fail? And then from that, I can learn like, oh, you know what? This command line tool, maybe we need to add this flag to it or something like that. So I think you have to, you have to treat your session logs are very valuable, I think. And it's not just like,
前几天，我直接就说：你知道吗？我打算直接去找 Claude——所有的数据都在这儿。去吧，去找出这个特定工具被使用的所有时间点。然后把关于我们每次调用这个工具的信息交给我，告诉我它是成功了还是失败了？然后从中我可以了解到，哦，你知道吗？这个命令行工具也许我们需要为它添加这个标志（flag）之类的。所以我觉得你必须，你必须把你的会话日志（session logs）看作是非常有价值的东西。它不仅仅是，
like, you know, it's not just the data, the hard data that you get out of it, but it's also like the learning experience that you, the engineer, get, right? Like, this is a whole new world, a whole new way of working, so you've got to go and kick the tire on it. And I think we all have to assume that there's a future world where token costs are a thousand times cheaper than they currently are. And if token costs were a thousand times cheaper than they currently are, then, you know, boy, like that would, that would enable everybody to do this sort of crazy stuff that you and I have been doing, Connor. And that is a very, a very interesting world. Yeah. I mean, I don't want to call people out, but I definitely have listened to folks on certain podcasts.
你知道的，它不仅仅是你从中获得的硬数据，也是你——作为一名工程师——获得的学习体验，对吧？这是一个全新的世界，一种全新的工作方式，所以你必须去亲自体验一把。我想我们都必须假设未来终会到来，那时 token 的成本将比现在便宜一千倍。如果 token 的成本比现在便宜一千倍，那么，天哪，那将使每个人都能做你和我一直在做的这种疯狂的事情，康纳。那将是一个非常、非常有趣的世界。是的。我的意思是，我不想点名道姓，但我确实听过某些播客上的家伙们，
that I listen to. And when they whine about what these models are capable of, I think in my head like it's user error. Like you haven't spent enough time learning how to like wield these tools. And I think it's a privileged position that we're at Nvidia and we get access to these tools. And like you said, I mean, I'm more concerned about my spend versus you. But that's just because I think you're a more confident New Yorker and I'm an apologetic Canadian type. I'm just waiting for someone to send me an email.
那些我常听的播客。当他们抱怨这些模型的能力不行时，我在心里想，这其实是用户操作失误（user error）。说明你花在学习如何驾驭这些工具上的时间还不够。我认为我们在英伟达能接触到这些工具，这是一种特权地位。就像你说的，比起你，我其实更关心我的花费。但那只是因为我觉得你是一个更有自信的纽约人，而我是一个带着歉意的加拿大人。我只是在等有人给我发邮件。
But I do agree that there's like an immense value from like daily driving these things. And even like if I'm using it for some like, you know, random, not even like auto research thing, you learn things from like staring at the trace, realizing like, you know, one time I was doing something with cursor and it had like failed to recognize both the JSON files that were storing some data and then like a Python script. And I was like, without going into details, I was just like, whoa, whoa, whoa, like, what's happening right now? And I started having like a meta conversation being like, why are you not surfacing the information
但我确实认为，日常高强度地使用这些东西具有巨大的价值。甚至，如果我是用它来做一些，你知道的，随意的、甚至不是自动研究的事情，你也会从盯着运行轨迹（trace）中学到东西。比如有一次我在用 Cursor 做某事，它既未能识别出存储某些数据的两个 JSON 文件，也未能识别出一个 Python 脚本。然后我就，在不涉及细节的情况下，当时我就想：等一下，等一下，等一下，这到底是怎么回事？我开始与它进行元对话（meta conversation），问它：“为什么你不把这些 JSON 中的信息浮现出来？”
in this JSON? And then it was like, there's no JSONs in these, like, this directory. And I was like, what? What is going on here? And then like 20 minutes later, after going back and forth with it, it realized that like somehow it had become, like, developed a blind spot to certain files in the repo. And then I was like, well, how do I make sure that this never happens again? again and it was like oh well we have these like dot for cursor i think it was like mdc which were like
然后它回答：“这个目录下没有 JSON。”当时我就懵了：什么？这到底是怎么回事？然后大约 20 分钟后，在和它来回交涉之后，它才意识到，不知何故，它对代码库中的某些文件产生了盲点。接着我就问：“那我该如何确保这种事情再也不会发生？”
the rules and it was like this is the first thing that i ingest and like i understand that you had like agents dot md or some markdown that stored some stuff that in that markdown it said you know blah blah and even without that i should have been able to look at everything in this repo but just for whatever reason i miss that but if you if it is essential that like this data is needs to be at the top of like the context for every conversation you have, just put like a little sentence in your dot MDC file or even just ask me to put that essential information there and like it'll never happen again. And that was like for something that wasn't like auto research related. I was just like asking it a question being confused and then was like, wait a second,
它回答说：“哦，好吧，我们有这些以 `.mdc` 结尾的 Cursor 文件，它们就像是规则。”它说：“这是我首先要摄取的东西，我明白你之前有 `agents.md` 或其他存储了一些东西的 Markdown 文件，那个 Markdown 里写着诸如巴拉巴拉的内容。即便没有那个，我也应该能够查看这个代码库中的所有内容，但不知出于什么原因我漏掉了。不过，如果你认为这些数据必须在每次对话的上下文的最顶端，只需在你的 `.mdc` 文件中加上一小句话，或者干脆让我把这些重要信息放在那里，那就绝对不会再发生这种事了。”这并非什么与自动研究相关的事情，我当时只是在向它提问并感到困惑，然后突然想：等一下，
like we're at the point now where it shouldn't be making this kind of mistake. And and then I realized that like, oh, like it still can make mistakes. If you put the. important information in the wrong spot. And like there are like basically places for whether you're using, you know, clod code, codex, cursor. Each harness is a bit different. And like I even asked it. I was like,
我们现在已经到了不应该犯这种错误的地步了。然后我意识到，哦，原来它依然会犯错。如果你把重要信息放错了地方的话。而且基本上，无论你使用的是 Claude Code、Codex 还是 Cursor，都有各自的适用场景。每个 harness 都略有不同。而且就像我甚至问过它一样，我当时就想：
yeah, I've run into this a lot where like harness differences, especially when you're doing like multi-agent orchestration stuff. You become very tied to the particular way that a harness works and that the harnesses tool, tooling works. And like I ran it, I had this weird thing where like initially I couldn't get, I couldn't get models other than.
是的，我经常遇到这种情况，就是 harness 的差异，特别是当你做多智能体编排之类的事情时。你会变得非常依赖于某个特定的 harness 运作方式以及该 harness 的工具链。而且就像我运行它时，我遇到了一个奇怪的情况，一开始我无法让，我无法让除了
Opus to like drive ClaudeCode well. And I thought that the models just were not capable of handling this workflow. But it turned out that really there was just like a bug in the structure of my skills that when it was going to launch, you know, a sub-agent, the way it was describing what to do was just not correct in that there was a better way to do this. And with Opus for, you know, maybe because they post-trained it to for the harness specifically or for whatever reason, it just was sort of smoothing over this, you know, this bug in my skills. I think you make a good point there that when something goes wrong with NOLM, you know, you have two options.
Opus 之外的模型很好地驱动 ClaudeCode。我以为这些模型根本无法处理这种工作流。但事实证明，实际上只是我的技能结构里有一个 bug，当它准备启动，你知道的，一个子智能体时，它描述要做什么的方式是不正确的，其实有更好的方法来实现这一点。而使用 Opus 时，可能因为他们专门针对 harness 对其进行了后训练，或者出于某种原因，它就这样，某种程度上平息了，你知道的，我技能里的这个 bug。我觉得你说的很有道理，当大模型出现问题时，你知道的，你有两个选择。
One, you can just tell it to fix it. Or if it's something that, you know, if you want to just put a band-aid over it, you know, you just tell it how to correct itself and move on. But if you're building like a repeatable, like, workflow or a skill, then you want to be like, no, hang on, like, you know, I'm going to be like a psychologist now. And like, you, like, you sit down with me and like, explain to me why you did this thing that you did. Like, don't, don't try to fix it. Just like, explain to me how we got here. And then, like, from that, you know, you can get insights into, into, you know, what you might need to adjust about, about your
第一，你直接告诉它修复。或者如果是那种，如果你只想打个补丁（band-aid），你只要告诉它如何纠正自己然后继续前进就行。但如果你正在构建一个可重复的工作流或技能，那你就会想：不，等等，你知道的，我现在要像个心理学家一样，你得坐下来跟我好好解释，你为什么要这么做？不要，不要试图直接修复它。而是向我解释我们是如何走到这一步的。然后从中，你知道的，你可以深入了解你可能需要对你的流程做出什么调整。
process. And, you know, part, I think part of this, you know, having, having, like, more reliable evals and having ways of like testing and evaluating skills is really important because of this. It is very challenging for auto research to do evals because most of the crazy behavior happens 24 to 48 to 72 hours into an auto research run, right? Most of the interesting weird bugs happened, you know, after there's been some compactions, after it's, you know, there's some context rot. And so I don't know how. to, I don't know how to reliably create a CI system for stuff that needs to run like 72 hours and currently costs, you know, many tokens. I think at one point over the weekend, so you suggested to me on like Friday, they're like, oh, like, you know, we should look at GPU mode.
而且，你知道的，我认为部分原因在于，拥有更可靠的评估（evals）以及测试和评估技能的方法非常重要，正是因为这一点。对于自动研究来说，进行评估（evals）是非常具有挑战性的，因为绝大多数疯狂的行为都发生在自动研究运行 24 到 48 到 72 小时之后，对吧？绝大多数有趣且奇怪的 bug 都发生在经历了一些压缩（compaction）、经历了一些上下文腐烂（context rot）之后。所以我不知道该如何，我不知道该如何为需要运行 72 小时且目前消耗大量 token 的任务可靠地创建一个 CI 系统。我想在周末的时候有那么一刻——你在周五的时候向我建议说：“哦，你知道的，我们可以看看 GPU 模式。”
The GPU mode is this GPU programming community and they have these regular coding contests of which my bots currently hold. the winning spot for like six of the seven or six of the five of the six problems. But so like I just like spun this up over the weekend and like tried out a bunch of new things. I think at one point over the weekend it was like 500 million tokens an hour or something. That's that, you know, before cashing. So fewer than that are uncashed. But it's still a lot of tokens. Yeah.
这个 GPU 模式是一个 GPU 编程社区，他们会定期举办编程竞赛，我的机器人目前在六个问题中的五个或六个问题里都占据着获胜位置。所以我就在周末快速启动了这个东西，并尝试了许多新东西。我想在周末的某个时候，它的速率达到了每小时 5 亿个 token 左右。那是，你知道的，在缓存之前。所以未缓存的token数量要少于这个数字。但那依然是大量的 token。是的。
Have you tried Nematron 3? ultra yet? No. You should try it. It's very fast. It's very fast. And yeah, I've been trying it out a lot, kicking the tires on it. I'll add it to my list of stuff to do.
你试过 Nemotron 3 Ultra 了吗？还没有。你应该试试。它非常快。非常快。而且，是的，我一直在尝试它，亲自体验了一把。我会把它加到我的待办事项列表里。
Yeah. It was funny. We had this meeting on Friday, and we're Connor and I were just chatting. And halfway through the meeting, I'm like, hang on. Connor, I got to go check on my agents. And Connor's like, yeah, I also have to go check on my agents. Yeah. And then I remarked, what does it say about us that we're meeting for like 60 minutes?
对。这挺搞笑的。我们在周五开会时，康纳和我当时正在闲聊。会议开到一半，我说：等一下。康纳，我得去照看一下我的智能体了。康纳说：对，我也得去照看我的智能体。然后我感叹道，我们开会开个 60 分钟，
And both of us need to go like garden our agents to, you know, kick them off. You know, one of mine just runs flawlessly by itself now for as long as I want. But other times when you're steering stuff, you do need to go check. And that was one of the things. You know, we should bring Colt on the guy that worked to Google and recently joined that gave that presentation about like the eight levels of agentic code. And because like one of the things that he remarked, which he's not the first person to remark this, we both have made the same statements and others have is that like, you know, we're, we're busier
结果两个人都得去“照料”各自的智能体，让他们去运行，这说明了我们什么？你知道的，我现在的一个智能体现在可以完全按照我想要的时长完美地自己运行了。但有时候当你指挥某些东西时，确实需要去查看一下。这就是其中之一。你知道的，我们可以把 Colt 请上节目，就是那个曾在谷歌工作、最近加入英伟达并做了关于“智能体化代码的八个阶段”演示的家伙。因为正如他所指出的——他并不是第一个指出这一点的人，我们俩以及其他人也都说过同样的言论——那就是，你知道的，我们现在变得更忙了。
than we've ever been before because these tools are like a unlock of so many different things. And well, also it feels like it's a race. It feels like it feels like there's a race, you know. I guess, yeah, a little bit, a little bit. Yeah, I mean, there's a lot of people doing this kind of research. and, you know, trying to figure out what's the best way to use these tools. But it's, yeah, it's this, it's this like you, you know, there was a period of time before I had figured out the right way to use these tools so that, you know, I could go to sleep and it would
比以往任何时候都要快，因为这些工具就像是解锁了许多不同的东西。而且，嗯，这也感觉像是一场比赛。感觉就像，感觉像有一场比赛，你知道的。我想，是的，有一点，有一点。是的，我的意思是，有很多 人在做这种研究，而且，你知道，试图找出使用这些工具的最佳方法。但 是，是的，就是这样，就是这样，你知道，在我找到使用这些工具的正确方法之前有一段时间，这样，你知道的，我可以去睡觉，然后它
just work. And like, it is, it is intoxicating while this thing is like making progress. And then like, whenever I would just like randomly wake up in the middle of the night, now I reach for my phone because like I serve my like little dashboards to my local IP address. So I just like, I go to my local IP address, colon, you know, whatever the port that I have it hosted on. And that was, that was another thing that I realized is I was like, wait a second, I have all these dashboards. I can serve all of this just like locally on my IP address with like, you know, I don't even know what the command is, but like, you know, usually on your desktop,
就会自己运转。而且，这东西在取得进展时确实让人着迷。然后，每当我半夜随便醒来时，现在我就会去拿手机，因为我把一些小仪表板托管在我的本地IP地址上。所以我只需要访问我的本地IP地址，加上，你知道，我托管它的端口号。然后，那是另一件我意识到事情，我想，等一下，我有所有这些仪表板。我可以在我的IP地址上本地托管所有这些，只需使用，你知道的，我甚至不知道是什么命令，但就像，通常在你的桌面上，
you go local hosts. But it's like one extra thing to do just so that you can look at it. And now, like, I go to watch TV, you know, I just like, well, I told you about my thing, my, where I had this Mattermost server where I can, you know, where all of my distributed agents that are running and multiple nodes are connected to and I can just go check on your phone. That's the, I haven't done that yet, you know, it's so that any time I'm going for a run. You got to go, you got to go cloud. You got to go. At the scale that you're at, you got to go cloud. It's funny. So I, I, um, I have a dashboard too and I usually watch the dashboard, but over the weekend, I didn't have to check the dashboard. I just like went to the GPU. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, every couple hours I was like,
你访问localhost。但这就像是多做了一步，只是为了能看一眼。现在，比如，我去看电视，你知道的，我只是，嗯，我跟你说过我的那个东西，我在那里有一个Mattermost服务器，在那里我可以，你知道，我所有正在运行的分布式代理和多个节点都连接到那里，我只要用手机去查看就行了。那是，我还没那样做呢，你知道，所以任何时候我去跑步。你得去，你得去云端。你得去。以你目前的规模，你得去云端。真有意思。所以，我，我，嗯，我也有一个仪表板，我通常会看那个仪表板，但周末的时候，我不需要检查仪表板。我只是去查看GPU。哦，对，对，对，对。你知道，每隔几个小时我就想，
oh, okay, well, we've, we've claimed. we've claimed prefix some. Yeah, that is so funny, yeah, because there's a, there's a, there's a couple of those as well. And like, yeah, you, if you're in your house or whatever, you can go and look. But then also, too, yeah, I just go check. Then you look at the status to see if you have a submission in the last couple hours. And sure enough, it's just cooking. And anyways, we should, we should, we should, we don't need to necessarily stop talking about AI.
哦，好吧，我们，我们认领了。我们认领了前缀。是的，太搞笑了，是的，因为也有，有，有几个那样的。而且，是的，如果你在家里或者其他地方，你可以去看看。不过话说回来，是的，我只是去检查一下。然后你看状态，看看过去几个小时内你有没有提交。果不其然，它正在全力运行。不管怎样，我们应该，我们应该，我们应该，我们不一定非要停止谈论人工智能。
But we'll wrap this as episode one is whatever, our latest updates. Be sure to check these show notes, either. in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我们将把这作为第一集进行总结，这就是我们最新的更新。请务必查看这些节目shownotes，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSP thepodcast.com上，里面有今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。高质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。其实不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。